maurice jones drew former raider former
jaguar
and of course always a bruin now
currently calling rams games on the
radio locally here in los angeles and
part of my
team at nfl network how are you mjd
i'm doing well rich sorry sorry i'm a
little late man i ran to the restroom
and uh took a little bit longer than i
thought okay all right
um look uh you know maurice no clock
you're strict about that maurice
maurice maurice you're supposed to say
you were getting an iv
that's the way it works i'm here i'm on
this whole thing and telling the truth
you know so i figure i
know the people they want to know why i
wasn't on time okay you know what
all right maurice jones drew here after
getting an iv on the rich eisen show
let's get into it why was jared goff
traded maurice
why was he trading it's so funny rich so
um it's not funny but like my phone's
been blowing up constantly because
obviously with the rams you talked about
calling the games there but the issue is
this
the last couple years jared's play
hasn't been up to par
and you know i the rams are in a win now
mo they've been in the window mode for a
long time
as you saw with todd gurley uh when he
wasn't playing
they you know they moved on from um
that's kind of been their forte if
you're not
putting up the numbers they don't see
the production or if they can't
project your production being high they
try to move on brandon cooks he had a
concussion issues
he was kind of coming close to the end
there so they removed they moved on from
him
and really what it came down to was that
they felt like they had a team this year
that probably could have made a run at
the super bowl
um and jared's play just wasn't up to
par
um we heard the comments obviously from
uh sean mcvay who's had those comments
since the miami game the miami uh
dolphins game where jared had four
turnovers
you started to hear the rumblings then
and some of the press conferences
um and you know i don't think jerry gets
enough credit
it may not look the part like the
mahomes and the aaron rodgers of the
world but he's a winner he's won
uh he's won here in la he's won the big
games he's won afc championship games
i think peter schrager none of what our
colleagues talked about he's beat drew
brees in the in the dome and he's
beating russell wilson in seattle
multiple times so
he has that winning pedigree i just
think that uh
the rams feel like there's much more
that the offense can be a little bit
more with a different quarterback and
they went out and got a guy who they
feel has a better arm talent and
um you know where we yeah all we can do
is wait to see
uh what stafford has for him so before
we get to the stafford part of it
so so you're saying the
to a first career start was a game where
he didn't perform very well
but the number of turnovers and special
teams touchdowns that the dolphins were
able to put on the board
just boat race the rams right out of
south florida that was where
things took a turn or were they already
turning before all that between mcveigh
and golf
watching 2019 kind of was like
the start of it right um not playing
well in chicago
and there was a couple games where he
just didn't play well and it was kind of
like
you know the year before he went on that
that immaculate run where he was
rolling in the playoffs you throw this
you beat the saint throwing the ball and
so everyone there was high expectation
um 2019 the offensive line gets hurt
todd's not the same there's a lot of
pressure on jared to to compete and win
games he doesn't do it
uh they missed the playoffs this year
was kind of a
okay we're gonna bounce back see what's
going on and then you just saw there
were some games where he was just so
inconsistent
there was games where he played lights
out then there were games where
you know he didn't play well and i think
that dolphins game was kind of the start
of when you start to hear
the stuff come out right from the
organization normally you don't hear
those things but
i think you know a lot of it was like we
don't know what else to do
uh there were some times and then those
situations where i just think
you know um the the football
relationship kind of was just ruined
in that point i wouldn't say i can't say
ruined it just started not to work for
either side and so
the rams are since i've been calling
their games and been working with them
they have moved on from top talented
guys
uh they don't have a problem doing it
and you know this has kind of been their
track record
maurice jones drew here on the rich
eisen show so how does stafford fit
in a better way than goff how does he
how is he the upgrade that um
bless need was hearing about or seeing
is necessary
and then went ahead and mortgaged two
more first-round picks out of the future
they're gonna go seven years without a
first round pick unless it gets
replenished
well i'll tell you this much rich they
don't they don't believe
in you know um that so for example the
jalen ramsay trade
they knew for those two years there
wasn't a guy that was going to come out
and be like jalen ramsey
we've seen jaylen ramsey lock it down
right and so i think they believe again
that there's no quarterback that's going
to come out in this draft and be a
matthew stafford
and so if if if you're i would you know
if that's how you see it and that's what
you think
then you make you pull the trigger you
make that trade happen
uh matthew stafford and then we all know
this is one of the better armed towns in
the game he throws it from all different
angles very similar pastor mahomes and
aaron rodgers
um tyler murray and russell wilson get
throw the ball from different platforms
um and i think uh bucky brooks has
talked about it a lot of guys have
talked about it but i believe
when you see matt leflore's offense
flourish with aaron rodgers and what it
looks like you're kind of like oh man
um and so you know sean mcveigh wants to
know if if if
matthew stafford can be that guy for
them to help them get over the hump also
we have to know this aaron donald's in
his prime
and jaylen ramsey's in their prime and
you don't want to waste
those guys who probably first ballot
hall of famers aaron dom for sure
um you don't want to waste their prime
right you want to try to get to as many
super bowls as possible
um and the rams they're very confident
that they can get to the super bowl uh
they feel like they have a team
that is built and ready to go um and so
they wanted they wanted to make a push
at it as a player you have to respect
that
uh i know for jared it doesn't feel good
to be like cast away in those type of
things but
you're in a situation where a team wants
you and you'll be able to go and play
for another team
and guys on the rams you know that when
you play for the los angeles they're
trying to win now
all the time and that's very similar to
how the pittsburgh steelers have been
that's very similar to how uh you know a
lot of teams that have been
perennial winners have been and so you
know the rams want to be in that
category
in the few minutes i have left with you
maurice jones drew break down super bowl
55 for me
uh who wins it and and how does that
happen what to look for
so on so forth uh rich i've said this
before and i'll say it again unless you
can score 40 points in the game you're
not going to beat the
chiefs they're 15 in one the one loss
that they have they've had is
when the raiders beat them the las vegas
raiders they beat them
uh well excuse me the lost oakland
raiders because they're still they still
have
they still got some stuff in oakland
there the lost oakland raiders
uh they scored 40 points and they played
lights out that game and so
when you look at the tampa bay
buccaneers as good as they are when you
watch the nfc championship game they've
dropped them they dropped a lot of
passes tom didn't have the best second
half
their defense created turnovers um but i
just believe that the chiefs showed
in the afc championship game that no
matter who they're going against
because the buffalo bills are one of the
hottest teams coming out uh are coming
into that game
they just boat race them and so uh when
they get on when they start playing the
way they've played the last couple weeks
the the chiefs are a tough team to beat
and so for me if you can't score 40
points
it's not going to be close yeah but
brady can right brady can definitely
score 40 points in
why not i don't i don't know because i
saw brady in the second half throw three
turnovers three picks
that becomes a problem because if you
throw if you turn the ball over against
the chiefs
it's gonna be uh different and i'm gonna
go back and watch the bucks chiefs game
but
from my memory i want to believe like in
the third quarter the teams were up by
like 14. it was like the end of the
third quarter they were up by 14 they
kind of
called off the dogs a little bit and
that's how the bucks came back
um i think it's going to be a great
super bowl but i think the chiefs have
too much
offense um for the for the buccaneers
well i mean
the last three quarters of their week 12
game they played them pretty much
straight up
you know so and they they only they only
gave up 27 they just scored 24
and a lot of them came late i just don't
know that you know that's what i'm
saying like those late touchdowns i
don't think you're gonna get those
i i i truly believe that chiefs kind of
went into like let's just get out of
this game
we're up by 14. let's get out of this
game and run the ball and try to get out
and that's when the defense locked down
and
tom figured it out and kind of made it
go but
i think if the chiefs are still throwing
the ball i mean tyra hill had 190 yards
in the first quarter
so let me just wrap it up this way then
uh do you think if the rams had matthew
stafford this
in january they'd still be playing right
now what do you think
i i think they would i think i think if
well to be honest with you i think if
jared goff was completely healthy and
aaron donald's completely healthy they
would have beat the packers
and then they would have probably beat
the buccaneer so they did it early in
the season with with the way their
defense and the way they were playing
um i i believe again i again that i'm a
rambly guy but
if cooper cup is out there aaron
donald's 100
and even with a nine finger jared goff
they should have ran the pack nine
finger jared goff i've never heard of
that phrase before
but so then why does golf have to go
maurice it did i was once told this in
the national football league when i
played like some people just don't get
along like
some people's personalities just don't
match up and i think
it i think this is more of a football
personality because
jared is an awesome dude everyone loves
him right from what i hear and i
actually worked out i actually rehabbed
with jared when he was a freshman at cal
so i know jared's a good guy
i just think that his football
personality is not what they're looking
for
right they may want a more of a fiery
guy a guy that's going to you know
bark back and do some different things
jared's real even kill he doesn't like
water off a duck's back that may be the
issue
but also you have to remember this too
rich if i'm paying you 100 million
dollars
i need production because if you're not
producing at that level
i can't convey that to the team that you
should be the guy
if that makes sense maurice thanks for
the time appreciate it i'll see you
i'll see you soon hopefully all right
see you back at you that's maurice jones
drew at mjd
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here